and a man arrested for killing three
people in an apartment last week
appeared in front of a judge again today
Spencer McDonald is accused of taking
the lives of his grandmother her
boyfriend and a maintenance worker 8
news now reporter Ryan Matthey sat front
row this morning in the courtroom joins
us now with how the D.A says mental
health could impact proceedings and more
on the apartment's liability
the family members are grappling with
the loss of their loved ones two males
in their 40s and another female in her
80s allegedly killed by 30-year-old
Spencer McDonald and after his second
court appearance Monday morning here at
the Regional Justice Center seemingly
his mental health may play a part in
this case
all right thank you everybody McDonald's
staring blankly at a Clark County Judge
Monday now with an appointed public
defender
Anna Clark his attorney confirms a
mental health evaluation will be done an
article from The Washington Post 10
years ago profiled McDonald and how his
schizophrenia diagnosis impacts his
family including the grandmother he's
accused of killing the death penalty
that's something that we would consider
in this case but Clark County district
attorney Steve Wilson says that
diagnosis has not yet been confirmed
impending that evaluation he would be
put in some sort of treatment facility
until he's found competent if at all in
McDonald's arrest report he admits to
killing the three and injuring another
so I don't think there's going to be a
question of whether he did it the real
question is going to be why he did it
there but likely be a lawsuit Richard
Harris Law Firm attorney Adam Gill
expects action against the apartment's
management too police documents show two
maintenance workers perform the welfare
check at Management's Direction one
survived the other did not they were
sent they were directed during their
course in scope of employment to go do
that welfare check so that does open
them up to liability which is another
reason that Metro is probably the
preferred way to to do the welfare check